oh my god
hello my name is markiplier welcome back
to three scary
games and to me spooky intro
did i scare you welcome to
mother's little helper which is a game
about me being mother's little helper
me being a mother and i have a little
helper i'm assuming it means that i'm
the little helper
[Music]
in the kitchen we've got company coming
over hello child
here to help out i don't know why mom
sounds so old your father's guests are
ravenous let's do our best to please
them
don't worry i'll always be here to help
i don't know i don't want it to be
simple
even the child can do it a ma
ma ma some herbs would be best
they should be in the cabin mom why are
you floating
mom why are you why are you floating
why why are you breathing like that ah
you uh
what is going on with you mom hey mom
all right hey don't you worry about a
thing that's what i'm here for
i'm your little helper jesus all right
you know how your father can get i don't
remember the beatings you know and zone
remember
i'm still here waiting okay you can cut
the attitude a little bit ma
i could drop it in the whole bottle
do i just drop the whole bottle in mom
why you
why are you breathing like that why
father get me some vegetables from the
shelves
where are you looking away from look me
in the eye ma look me in the eye aren't
you looking at me
like seeing you know she kind of looks a
bit like you
the resemblance is uncanny
no i can't tell the difference okay
i don't know all right a vet that's
i don't know if you think that's
supposed to be a carrot um
mine is ain't no carrot carrots aren't
orange
all the way down to its flared base all
right fine ma
okay sure whatever you whatever you say
let me just say drop it here
i can't go on hold chop it up nice okay
you got
ma oh my god
ah yeah i love it when my carrot
explodes into blood balls and bounce
into infinitesimal small
bases on the floor i love that
squeaking i'm crazy i'm squeaking oh i'm
done now
can you look in the lord i think it is
what has what we need
ma i don't think it's been called the
larder since
1682 i think we call it the pantry but
all right
you got it man look at the onions this
is where i die
this is where you kill me why aren't you
looking at me man why oh we mustn't
terry he might get cross
oh no what what what is
why is the air snowing upwards
okay look at that snotty ma that's a
pumpkin
but i don't know what's wrong with you
ma i think that quickly or it won't turn
out right
all right you know what my oh just drop
it in hole like the can of spike
okay just pop all right yeah don't cut
that off
sorry mom oh no ma wait no hang on
pick up me
your worms are loose you got ma
how you uh are you breathing
you breathing good you breathe good you
breathe good
my god i promised him where you left me
okay i wasn't worried about that why am
i holding it like this
i'm not holding it by the eyes why am i
who holds a fish by the face
oh they are ravenous okay ma i gotta
chop this one up dude we can't leave it
like that
carve it into pieces okay you got it ma
wumpus
champa slumpus lumpus
why is that finally greeter should be
tucked away in the corner of the ladder
oh no
okay oh whoa oh okay
all right
my my you got
got some schmutz on your face listen now
the the resemblance is uncanny
you're beautiful just like oh my god
i thought you were here to help ah you
know what oh
shoot hey you know yeah of course i
pick up bleach oh good that's fun
you got it ma i'm mama's a little helper
find your way back don't leave me alone
with him okay
hurry up you got it i see why you're
making me do all this
i see
oh oh my god
ma ma where'd you go pick up meal yeah
delicious fish head stew
i love my mom's authentic korean cooking
here
where are you did you run oh god oh
no oh the eye very glitter
dinner's ding ding ding is ready
everybody eat up
yeah have a good one
and the lesson here is that there's
nothing quite like
a home-cooked meal made by family
i love that that was fantastic i was
weirded out the whole way
through just disturbing but i liked it
that was very good
i thought that was fantastic really did
a good job on that one thank you george
simpsons and jay clipperton
all right moving on oh i don't like that
oh i don't like that at all welcome to
black eyes
i don't know if this game is going to
give me black eyes by punching me
or there's something with black eyes
that i should be aware of
don't believe her remember she's always
whatever you do don't let her in
don't answer the door to your room
whatever you do don't let her in i'm
thinking i should answer the door to my
room
i don't know what you about you guys but
i think that i should really let
her in i should really open the door to
my room
erg i can't sleep might as well explore
am i supposed to be a child is that what
i'm supposed to be ah
is this a race car bed oh no it's even
better it's a
boat bed holy crap that's awesome got my
fidget spinner i got my
uk plugs this is dope
20 c's oh this is oh yeah
look at this little cutie wait it's got
black eyes
demon all right okay oh
wow giddy up horsey
man i really like boats apparently look
at me look at you
look at you look at oh look at you
oh my god don't look at you this could
be a big black eye for all i know
oh look at you look at all of you
who's bling-blonging i got a lot of toys
what more could i ask for
my my room all right
oh no where did i put my key my key
my key to my own door
is it like under something
hello
oh what the hell what
what oh hey
oh hey oh hey
okay nothing to say about that not a
thing
where i gotta find my key where is mikey
yeah good good question where is my key
okay
at least i got a sword to defend myself
with well my room is now an absolute
garbage heap
i'm not sure if that's what i was
supposed to do but that's what a
boy
who did that oh you closed
why'd you close why have you closed your
doors to the public
oh what uh i'm dead i fell through the
floor
what oh come on are you kidding me
i just spent like six minutes wandering
this room
oh man oh man
no where did i put my key squeak
oh so that okay so it's okay so it is
triggers
okay so some oh okay
weird all right
oh my goodness i just used the big
wheels
oh that was a bad wheel to use that was
bad wheel
that was the bad wheel that was the bad
wheel
oh that was the ball hey hi hello
hi ho hi whoa
oh hey my stuff
what the hell why did i not notice this
before i'm guessing i need to find more
wheels
oh seven three one well that seems
important
now where would i be oh i see
okay my secret toy chest uh well
seven three one and oh
yay i did it i did it
and now i will open it up i will open it
up
i will open it i will open it up
now i will open it up
oh there we go okay hello
oh they look so grumpy oh
no don't cry you grumpy guses oh don't
cry
i'll take that thank you oh don't cry
grumpies
oh don't cry it's totally fine
hello
hello ah good yes this is fine
hello kitty kitty
pretty kitty cat where
are you at pretty kitty cat
when the drugs kick in oh my god
that's fine that's nothing you think
that's something that's nothing
that's nothing to me saying that a
million times
wow oh wow
okay uh is this my sister's room or
something
um man my
robo brain oh hi
the baby is crying baby
you okay baby well i don't exactly know
what i'm supposed to see
or do but i'm not seeing a whole lot and
i'm not doing much of anything
oh okay what was that oh hi
protect your sister at all costs
whatever you do don't let
what's wrong with my sister what
what on june 5th two kids mysteriously
disappeared from a residential house in
parkerville police are investigating the
case no suspects have currently been
found yet
police suspect foul play kidnapping or
murder one police officer found a
picture of
a kid with black eyes the picture was
found at the doorstep
and laid in a pool of blood forensics
are still yet to confirm who the blood
belongs to
the parents were out of town and have
been notified of the horrific
incident
[Music]
well that was black eyes i think i got
punched in the eyes with spoops that was
pretty good
i had minor death from fall through the
floor syndrome but i'm gonna assume that
was canon and supposed to happen
i didn't break a game again it just
happened that way but i liked that
i liked that a lot that was very good
moving on all right welcome to veiled
now veiled is a point-and-click style
adventure horror game
much like if you remember way way back
when
like uh what was the name of it help me
lexi and help me what was the name of it
the point and click oh
oh max mortis there's ex
mortis right but it looked like ex
mortis i have no any idea if it's
anything like that
but given that it's point and click and
it's kind of retro i think it's gonna be
pretty cool
oh wow look at this dial-up modem it has
been one year since the
incident one endlessly long year of
looking for the truth
you know your child is alive all the
answers must be out there
okay oh
your bag is empty i didn't know i was
playing now oh
hours pass you're exhausted
[Music]
that looks like a pug you finally arrive
at the location you've been given
better keep a low profile and go through
the woods
why go back in the car you shudder at
what you had to do to obtain this
address
no way you're backing out now are you
sure about that
you sure about that okay okay enter the
forest
you enter the forest
like so you make sure that scary music
and ambiance is really pumped up to the
max
we need the soundscape to really
encapsulate people so that they get the
full immersive horror experience
ominous twisted trees get like creaking
and swaying of trees and the wind
watch you venture deeper into the woods
give me a hooten of a howl
of owl of a howl who now everything
looks so quiet here
you shiver give me a man shivering
actually record yourself going
good thank you you continue until you
reach the house
the property is closed off by a large
gate is that a rabbit it is too high to
climb over
is your child really here abandoned
tools
among the rusty tools lies a big iron
bar
this may be useful to break the chain
seems sturdy enough
not very subtle but you need to get in
okay
there's also a rabbit look at the gate
it's locked by an old rusty chain it has
seen better days maybe there's a way to
break it
well i got it you put all your weight on
the bar the chain finally surrenders
the gate opens with a creaking noise you
enter from the front yard put in a clang
and a creek
oh that's lovely art this mansion once
opulent looks rather abandoned
a towering statue seems to watch over
the property
right maybe best not to knock on the
door you know what i mean
examine the statue strange slender dark
silhouettes they represent a family but
their alien looks give you chills
let's uh let's not knock on the door
let's go around the right corner
i'm sure knocking on the door would
probably be okay but i'm not gonna risk
it at this point
the way to the back is blocked by a
large empty ditch a moat
did i have a moat at this mansion it's
not dry enough to cross
it's a moat you caught something moving
on the first floor
what did i catch moving on the first
floor examine the building crossing the
ditch does not seem like a good idea how
big is this ditch
is it actually a moat you wouldn't want
to get stuck
yeah sure okay you can distinguish a
ghostly figure through the window
that's always good you call it out but
it suddenly fades away
why would i call it out if i'm trying to
be quiet why wouldn't i have just driven
my car up here if i was gonna shout at
the windows
all right i'll go back to the front yard
then i guess maybe there's another way
around
how about the left side you walk along
an overgrown french garden
there is a shed on the left the shed is
not locked
okay cool good
[Music]
thick layer of dust covers everything
nothing has been touched in a long time
it's weird considering i saw people in
the house a ladder rests on the side of
the bench
it could be useful to enter the house
i'll take that
it's heavier than it looks hopefully you
won't have to carry it around for too
long
all right interesting
search among the clutter warped wood
planks and broken windows nothing useful
in there
all right i guess i'm done here there's
a shed off to the left okay
let's just go to the backyard real quick
athletes in the backyard
oh my goodness a tiled terrace is
nestled at the back of the house
okay inspect the window the shutters are
not fully closed and the window behind
them seems open
if you had a way to get up there you
could sneak inside
oh i'll do just that you put the ladder
against the wall it is tall enough to
reach the window
you climb the ladder and enter the house
always a good thing this was the
objective
as you enter you see someone rushing
through the door just below you
who was he you run after him why would
you do
that why would you do that terrible idea
the man has disappeared through the door
in front of you
surely he must know something or i'll
follow the man
you throw yourself at the door in vain
it is desperately shut
but as you inspect it you find strange
contraption beside it
there's a small box besides the door
this high-tech device feels
out of place here yeah a little bit
strange it seems like some sort of
biometric device
apparently it needs to scan your eye and
your finger
so i need to get an eye and a finger is
what you're saying
simple as that all right let's go left
lock from the other side never mind
let's go to the right you grasp the cold
handle the door seems to weep
as you push it open that's not what
normal doors do in my experience
but what do i know a classy dining room
the silverware has been set and the
dinner is ready to be served
while this decorum was someone expected
maybe i should have knocked
look at the buffet you take a closer
look at the frames on the buffet
a few family photos are on display okay
good look at the photo the smile on the
man's face makes you uneasy
smiling kid pretty uptight the wedding
photo catch your attention
why
okay a happy couple it's the same man
that the other photograph
only much younger maybe they're your
hosts
i don't know because you found breaking
it the frame is missing a glass panel
that's odd yeah a little bit i'll just
take this for myself
thank you broke into your house gonna
steal your wedding photo hope you don't
mind
your wife might be dead or something but
i'm taking this for me
not even gonna sell it you uncover a
hidden compartment with a tape in it
perfectly normal you take the tape and
inspect it
to my baby is written on the label yeah
it
seems important i'll just take this
alexia record yourself being indecisive
kind of like oh well i don't know if i
should do this you know what i mean
put that in there also lixian feel free
to completely ignore everything i'm
asking you to do
i don't know if this is too too
cumbersome just
i apologize i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry
psych inspect the table only one plate
has been served
okay oh ew
france quasa apparently it looks like a
foot
is that a foot is that a foot yikes no
thanks
yikes french food no thank you yeah i
think it looks like a
foot it's not a foot to the foot might
be a foot
or is it a foot okay let me go back to
the main hall
i think i can go upstairs maybe because
i got this tape i just need to find a
place to play it i didn't think that
this was kind of time period that would
have
tape cassettes but whatever you may find
some leads on the fr i guess i did drive
here so yeah
probably okay what a stark contrast the
persian carpets on the floor feel rather
nice but the ceiling however is falling
off
yeah okay how about this door the door
is locked from the other side
you hear humming coming from the room oh
interesting
you knock on the door but no one answers
does the humming stop
what kind of madman am i i broke into
this house where clearly there are
either people or ghosts
either way you wouldn't go knocking on
random doors
no no no no no the door opens yeah
squeak hello anybody here don't mind me
weirdo coming through this bedroom is
rather cozy
expect the door the door is jammed the
bed it seems to have been used recently
yes bed's been used recently there's a
family album here
great more pictures for me to nab wow
these look
precious and valuable to someone
everyone looks sad
great you enter the room
wow what is that what am i saying what
am i looking at
a dirty bathroom what am i looking at
over here search this thing
you come closer to the sink i don't know
if i want to
i really don't know if i want to oh
my goodness hey i need that
apparently ew as you try to repress a
heave you start to seriously question
this place
i'ma take this eyeball but first i'm
going to expect this it's empty of
its contents
yoink as gross as touching this eye is
it may work on the door scanner
it's still warm
great as you take the eye you hear a
loud tumbling noise coming from the
bedroom behind
tumbling someone doing gymnastics over
there
tumbling
the bottom of the tub is filled with
caked goo gross i'll just take
yeah it's caked goo all right very
disgusting
go through the door why would i go
through their store what is on the other
side
i don't know that's why i went through
it
oh a small storage room
great i love this the gentle heat feels
comforting the small iron door is locked
maybe the key is there somewhere there
where's there okay let's go see what the
tumbling in the bedroom was all about
okay back to the bedroom who's tumbling
in there
oh what if i look what is that thing
well i don't know what it is
you tell me oh the stench from it makes
you rush
what am i looking at you get a closer
look and notice its surface is slowly
pulsing
oh oh lord something is spurting from
one of its pores
it's sporey
approach the dark heap yep you step
closer to the creature trying to control
your nausea
this is great oh my god
hey a key you realize it was a key
emerging from the goo
i'll take that yoink trying not to touch
the flesh you grab the key with the tip
of your fingers
you hear a very loud noise it's waking
up
what do you mean how do you know that it
seems to be growing
well back to the bull it's coming out
well back to the bathroom
you rushed to the bathroom hoping it
won't follow you there well it's up
tells me it might
all right cool it is following you well
great
it is still coming use the key the good
thing that was the key to that
door jesus
he found on the creature oh no
you lock the door behind you hoping that
it will keep the hideous thing
away it is pitch black in there
okay is that bones the bright tube light
hurts your eyes
what you discover doesn't make you very
hopeful yeah it's bones all right
planks have been torn away looks like
the person here was making an escape you
can see a room below
read the scribblings the occupant was
counting
days and many days have passed
apparently
the skin has shrunk around the skinny
bones it's practically mummified
wonderful anyway i'm gonna try to go
down below you start kicking the
remaining planks hard
their moldy remains break easily you
pass your head in the hole
and slip
head first crash
you fall hard into an unknown room like
seeing at a crash a thunk and a
you grunting oh try to make your
emulation of the roblox oof
oh perfect and then send me that sound
file oh
the small lounge seems to lead up to a
steep staircase
okay so i'm behind that locked door you
notice the lock on the door was
on you unlock it and open the door sure
yeah i'll leave that open
i'm not worried about any giant blobs
coming after me look at the hole that's
where you came from
let's hope the thing won't follow you
you cautiously start to climb it's
pretty steep
it's like three steps what do you mean
start to climb it's three oh
what the hell the stairs lead up to the
first floor
the first floor up the stairs up these
stairs is i go
okay i'm confused now about the layout
of this house a long corridor spreads
before you
you try to be quiet but the flooring is
squeaky
enter the room you slowly push the door
and enter the room
[Music]
this looks like a child's room a small
desk full of toys
great good i have a cassette your
attention is caught by a toy cassette
player
i have a cassette don't i there's no
tape in it play the tape you insert the
tape and press play
a lullaby starts playing heartbreaking
well i'm glad i did that maybe that'll
soothe
the gelatinous beast let's pick the
frames
there are frames on the wall a set of
formal family photographs
inspect the frames quadruplets
how unusual yeah how unusual
almost freaky deaky one might say okay i
guess i'll just
go then see you around
kids see you around let's go down the
hallway
i love this by the way i i know it's
slow paced but it's just
it's perfect the corridor turns and
opens up into a larger room
strange room it looks like a bedroom but
the main
furniture are gone okay examine the
shelves
an odd collection of mismatched books
and artifact
you pick one but can't decipher the
language you approach the closed
door oh big closed door okay
[Music]
a wooden sliding door a beautiful mural
is planted on it
there's a trinket over here it's a large
seashell with fragrant beads inside
the door seems loosely locked from the
other side you can distinguish the
silhouette of a simple latch between the
two doors
you could probably push it up with a
thin
object do i have i have an eyeball well
that ain't no
thin object but i could probably find
one
depending on where i look of course but
i could probably find one so i can take
this eyeball at least to the
bioscanner and see what it can do about
it and then try to find something for
the uh
latch the eye's not enough okay so i
can't operate it just yet
so i need to get some kind of a
fingerprint let me go back upstairs and
see what happens
if what
okay that door is now open the creature
came from here
you would rather not know what is inside
i would like to know what's inside
what are you talking about there's no
way you're going back there oh
don't be a big baby come on just go back
there come on it's not so bad
this is a big blood blob oh the curtains
oh the curtains you slowly approach your
hand
and pull the curtain open good lord the
poor
child what am i looking at quick you
must help him who
why how don't you what are you looking
at what with difficulty you untie the
rope on his ankle but it's too late
oh he's dead
oh no who could have done that you start
to weep thinking about your oh it's my
kid
[Music]
are you reaching close john's eyes you
know something in his hand
what is it a card this is a tarot card
the hanged man how ironic is it is that
a sick
joke what's happening his skin is
suddenly very hot
what oh my god uh
wha wha you can't believe what just
happened
poor kid it breaks your heart he just
burst into flames
we we pour up breaks your heart when
your kid dies and then explodes into
fire
hate it yeah god damn okay well
guess that's all there is to it then i
guess i'll go home maybe i could use a
tarot card to
unlatch it i guess lift the lock you
insert the card between
the two doors you gently push lash up
and slide open the door
you're immediately seized by a strong
accurate smell hey i like that give me
give me a taste of that the memory of
the creature flashed before your eyes
but you have to press on
why does it flash before my eyes do i
want to know
something terrible happened here okay
look in the mirror let's take a look at
me the reflection you see
something lying in the tub yeah
you gather your mental strength and
slowly peek at the tub
oh someone is lying inside the tub
lifeless am i crazy this right here
if you squint hard enough that looks
less like a normal hand and that looks
like
the amnesia monster's big old club hand
with long
finger nails am i crazy or does that
look like that i might be crazy
little bits of mold are floating in the
plastic blood okay let's examine
why did she do that what is happening
here examine the hand yeah i'll take one
of those
you lean closer to the hand
mind if i borrow one of these bad boys
here
the hand of the woman is hanging from
the side of the tub
despite bright red painted nails the
bloated skin is dark
and reminds you of the creature if this
hand belongs to the owner it may work on
the electronic lock
if only you had some way to take it with
you you're right about that
i don't have that unfortunately
oh boy scissors what are you gonna do
with those scissors
you can't believe that you are thinking
about this
this house starts to wait on you
you lean closer to the hand elixir and
cue up the snip snip sound effect
here we go snip snip the horror of the
situation is numbing
the blade cuts through flesh easily it
feels like there wasn't any solid bones
great good stuff you almost scream as
the hand retracts and the body
disappears inside the tub
okay you can't see anything through the
crimson water
ripple suddenly appears a technical
emergency
another technical burst out of the dark
mass swinging erratically
you dodged this one but may not be so
lucky next time well look at this
creature your eyes widen in horror
you need to get out of here fast you
stumble back paralyzed
oh boy oh boy
it keeps coming out where is all this
coming from i'm looking in the mirror
this keeps coming out
how is this possible oh smaller
tentacles join the party
oh oh no it's getting
dangerously close i'm getting out of
here you crawl out of the bath i'm
crawling out of the bathroom
okay it knows you're here
it's coming after you now oh
oh how could it be so big oh my god look
at that thing adrenaline is basically
that can't be real
oh my god i'm you know i'd probably go
i'm gonna go now i'm gonna go you know
what i'm not gonna stick around for that
oh
oh throw uh oh
head bleeding you're unable to move the
darkness reaches
your body and crush you i guess i wasn't
fast enough
oh you're we're here okay good snip snap
snip the snoppity snap
snip snap stupidity snoop snippety snip
snip the snip snap snoop
should i look inside the trunk snippety
snip snap stupid snoo
okay i'm out here how do you do okay
well i'm not paralyzed by fear this
time just to be snappy stupid okay
goodbye
you face back and start to run yeah
good move good move good move
this is still coming run to the stairs
out of breath you're rushing down the
stairs you spend like 10 feet man
cool your jets whoa ah that's a tentacle
you throw yourself down but the tentacle
grabs your feet
you lose balance and tumble down the
stairs out
elixir and put in the proper sound
effects you feel dizzy stand up and run
you get back on your feet and run to the
lounge yeah you know what waiting
probably not the best idea
you almost reach the hall you boom
inside the hall and shut the door behind
you
that'll stop it long tentacles on that
one you hear the creature crashing on
the door
thankfully it doesn't open from this
side you are in the main hall all right
let's go to the bioscanner well this was
problematic i hope the finger hasn't
turned into identical
there's a small box besides the door
this high-tech feels out of place
oh lord what are you doing you press
both eye and finger under the scanner
you squish them hard and you eventually
get a reading
squish i don't think that i you were
supposed to squish into there the result
of the using the scanners is a bit messy
but it worked
you hear the door unlock nothing stands
between the man and you now
this [ __ ] dude you dive into the
patches that just opened
oh i'm gonna get you i'll get you man
all these weird blobs these weird
tentacles no good for anybody
just as you pass the door it closes
behind you
a huge staircase unfolds before you you
delve
down into the unknown complex
at some point the stairs ends into a
large
corridor this looks like outlast
remember in the end when you're in the
medical corridor and someone gets pulled
through the vent right there that's what
this looks like right now
i wonder if it is there's a single door
at the end with
light coming out of it okay
you open the door the light is blinding
at first
okay you hear the door locked behind you
quickly after you enter
after a few moments the silence is
broken by a crackling speaker sound
well we were waiting for you sir please
make yourself comfortable and grab a
seat sure
this seems to open up to another room
you can't see its contents from here
sure i'll sit indulge me and take a seat
please
you may have all night but that's not
the case for everyone here
reluctantly you approach the chair let's
make a little experiment
you and i would you once see did you
finally get a sight of what is behind
the glass
oh another dark entity lies inert
in the other room you don't understand
what is expected of you now
after a few moments of silence the man's
voice booms again
a touching rewinding really i'd hate to
interrupt but unfortunately we need to
go on with the procedure
would you mind having a closer look at
our friend here
sure you fight your instinctive disgust
and try to focus your attention on the
creature before you
oh suddenly it starts to move and rise
its shape looks strangely humanoid now
almost familiar you start to cry okay
that's enough we both know what you are
seeking here
i can fulfill your wish but you need to
do one thing for me first
check the tray on the board please okay
i have no idea what's happening i'm
ready and willing oh
the saturated voice is more in it more
and more assertive you can be together
again you know
but before that i need you to administer
yourself my special treatment
oh goody okay as your will
falters you take the syringe in your
hand you can't stop the tears flowing
down your face
what's gonna happen if you do that well
there's no other option so i guess you
know
do it now screams the voice okay
sure your mind is broken there's nothing
you can do now
you see yourself inserting the needle
inside your arm and press the syringe
what now i have two hands
oh boy uh suddenly a tighter pain rushes
through your whole body oh my goodness
you can't move you can't breathe and a
nightmarish buzzing sound is filling
your ears
as you feel your body stretch and change
everything becomes more and more distant
even the sound even the pain is fading
out except for a small humming voice
[Music]
as the suffering slowly fades you start
to remember
that voice that you missed for so long
now
and that sweet face daddy
the end veil
a game made for
my remy business and nicholas millet
thank you for playing
i don't know if that was supposed to be
a touching moment at the end there but
it's in the back of my mind i just saw
like a big hand slaps on this on the on
the window it's just like
boom daddy
oh all right that was great i loved that
every second of that i loved
it was a little slow like with the
like the stylization of loading and
unloading through the through the
different places
i feel like it could have been better
served if it was just a little bit
faster but
still for the style i love the
commitment to it it was great fantastic
i really enjoyed that
thoroughly very very good what a
wonderful experience
many likes for you many big
subscriptions for you
many ring-a-ding-dongs of the bell for
you thank you
all right that is it for three scary
games with three scary games technically
three scary games pretty good deal i've
got a huge
this has been the heist with markiplier
four thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want more scary games
write them down in the comments below
or in the description right down below
ring that bell ring ring please do and
as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye